[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the journalist and author christina
patterson
and leader writer at the daily telegraph
tim stanley
there they are so let's have a look at
what's on those front pages
the sunday express has a plea to the pm
from the travel industry to slash the
cost of covered tests
in an effort to kick-start the sector's
recovery
universities refuse to stop online
teaching despite having the go-ahead to
return to fully face-to-face lessons
that's on the front of the sunday times
the world will soon face catastrophe
from climate breakdown if urgent action
is not taken warns the uk minister in
charge of the upcoming cop
26 talks alok sharma boris johnson's
green agenda is plunged into chaos
with fears working-class families will
be the most affected
sorry but geronimo has to die cabinet
minister george eustis defends
the decision to put down the alpaca with
tb that's an exclusive in the mail on
sunday
on the front of the ft the fierce battle
for the supermarket chain morrisons
continues as potential buyers raised the
stakes
the mirror features dominic raw on its
front page and his alleged movements
following a trip to the amber plus
france and the daily star has the latest
developments
in the tv show love island
and we are joined tonight by christina
patterson and tim stanley thank you so
much for joining us
both of you um let's kick off with the
sunday times
um tonto pm threatened to demote
sooner christina what's all this about
well yet again minister shows his true
cousin
um he's been apparently he's obsessed
with the polls and particularly with
internal polling
and in particular with a recent
conservative home poll
which uh cements the view that rishi
soon neck is by far the most popular
politician in the cabinet and that boris
johnson's popularity ratings have
plunged
and this appears to upset boris johnson
a lot
we know he doesn't like competition and
rishi sunak
leaked or somebody leaped the fact that
wishy soonak was writing
an aletto to boris johnson to urge
um loosening the restrictions on travel
which it has to be said have been a
complete and utter mess
and this apparently enraged boris
johnson so much he's in a meeting on
monday morning he said
essentially he said he threatened to
demote him and said he might make him a
health minister
and apparently there were about 10
people present
and it was not said in jest so
if i ever issue soon i mean i wouldn't
be that worried because i would know
that i was considerably more popular
than the prime minister
but again it shows that boris johnson is
not a nice man and is not
loyal to his colleagues okay tim what do
you think how much truth do you think
there is to this
well i don't know because what we're
getting right now
is one account i can understand why the
prime minister might be frustrated that
he didn't receive what was apparently a
very important piece of communication
maybe he was speaking more in jest than
he was speaking
literally but i think you step back from
this what's going on here is that
chancellors and prime ministers have
very different tasks
prime minister has to think of
everything the chancellor primarily has
to think of one thing
which is the economy and what rishi
sunax been thinking about
is first of all the impact of
restrictions
upon the economic recovery post covid
he's also thinking about the long-term
costs of the various plans that the
prime minister and the tory party have
signed up to
and putting those two things together
you have an economy which is not in the
greatest shape
you have receipts are bound to be down
you have a vast amount of spending
a lot of outlay that britain's gone
through in the last 18 months because of
furlough
and on top of that the government has a
long list
of things it was committed to before the
pandemic
and after the pandemic including the
environment and social care reform
now right now rishi sunak yes is very
popular and he's very popular because he
was the chancellor during furlough
and because many people feel that it was
his generosity and his management
that got the country economically
through the crash plus the economy seems
to be rebounding which also works in his
favor too
but i would be wary of any polls right
now that say the chance is more popular
prime minister because
the chancellor's going to have to start
actually making firm commitments on
spending
and on tax and we may well be looking
forward to tax
rises so if i was the prime minister i
wouldn't be too worried about my job
right now
because in a few months time rush's
sunac could be quite unpopular
interesting um you mentioned the
environment let's pick up on that
because the front of the sunday
telegraph
about the pm's net zero target and
so many people have said well how are we
actually going to achieve this target
um the sunday telegraph saying that his
push has been plunged into chaos
why christina well uh because
there are certain areas where having
your cake and eating it
doesn't work terribly well and one of
them is during the pandemic
and another is when you're dealing with
uh what is clearing clearly an
incredibly serious
climate crisis we now have the evidence
very uh
horribly in front of us in the form of
wildfires
raging through greece and many parts of
the world at the moment southern europe
and so on
so um boris johnson wants to look green
he's hosting the cop 20
uh one twenty two whatever it is twenty
six sixty
yeah there's been many thoughts
and and he wants to look you know like a
global leader strutting around the world
stage
as if he's uh you know the pioneer and
leader of all this but that's not
actually going to work out very well
not least because we are still pushing
fossil fuels in all kinds of ways but
also because it's going to be extremely
expensive
and boris johnson needs to keep the
so-called red wall
seats on the side and of course
those are among the groups that are
going to be hardest hit
by having to change your way of life
very considerably
and getting rid of your boiler and
getting rid of your car
and insulating your house and all these
things which are very expensive
and there is no cheap way to get to
green energy and there's no cheap way to
get to
zero carbon so i can see why the tories
are panicking about this you can't
reach that target in in a kind of
pain-free way
i know that boris johnson doesn't like
pain he doesn't like inflicting pain
and he doesn't like to be on popular but
there are very unpopular decisions that
are going to have to be made on this
tim what do you make because um we've
got
alex sharma internationally everyone's
saying cop26 we have to have
concrete action coming out of cop26 the
observer saying we're on the brink of
catastrophe warns tory climate chief
but um as christina was saying there
we've had
no form of action from within simply
because it is so unpopular because it's
so expensive to do the government would
say
that it has taken action in terms of
settling targets and passing laws
but of course you then actually have to
pay but you have to actually then spend
money
either to change people's consumer
habits which means that you or i have to
spend money to replace the boiler or
replace the car with an electric version
and then secondly you have to spend
money on infrastructure so that these
things will work the classic example is
electric cars
not only do we have to switch to
electric cars as consumers but there
also have to be points available
everywhere so that people can charge
their car it's not good enough just to
pass a law saying by this date
everyone must be electric uh if we don't
have the infrastructure for everyone to
go electric
so that that's the problem the
government would say it is taking a leap
and it is taking a leap globally it is
setting very very ambitious targets for
itself
what it's not doing right now is
leveling with consumers about how much
it will cost and actually detailing
in a convincing way what it will spend
to make it happen
the government has committed 12 billion
thus far to the development of green
infrastructure
you're probably looking at a final more
realistic figure of several times that
each year to to to meet the government's
own targets
so that's the problem and again to take
it back to what we're discussing earlier
where does money come from this well
that's where the treasury comes in
and as far as rishi sunac is concerned
he's got to find money for
social care he's got to find money for
the cost of the coveted recovery
for leveling up all these sorts of
things and on top of that
we are imposing this green revolution
which i think most people
watching thinks needs to be done
decarbonization is the future these
green technologies
can in the long run not only be cleaner
but even cheaper
you just look at the way in which the
price of solar is going down so
dramatically so we mustn't regard this
necessarily as a bad thing but in the
short run
it's an expensive thing and the tories
have got to level with people about that
um christina you know it comes
on the um the eve of this ipcc
which is an integral intergovernmental
panel on climate change
they're publishing this report tomorrow
and they're going to say we're on the
edge of complete disaster
and what is al-aqsham al-aqsr saying
about it
well when he's not flying around the
world and i think he's flown to
30 countries somehow amazingly
miraculously bypassing
all of the travel restrictions that have
been incumbent upon everybody else
when he's not flying around the world uh
emitting at carbon
dioxide then he is apparently very
worried about at all
and he is absolutely right to be worried
about it all i mean i have to say that
at the moment if you look at the fires
and if you look at the rising
temperatures
and the reports that are emerging all
the time
about changing climate even in the uk
it is incredibly worrying i think there
have been plenty of climate deniers
in the past and there are still some but
it's really really hard to look at the
evidence
even to look at the weather on a daily
basis and not see that something
real is happening here so i think that
what has changed a lot
in the last two year or so maybe two or
three years and not just because of
greater tinberg is that
that argument is operating the same way
we do
know that climate change is real the
question is what you do about it and it
is an emergency
okay let's talk about universities
what's the sunday time saying about uh
universities refusing to end online
lessons tim
this is astonishing other aspects of the
economy have totally opened up
some universities are going to maintain
are going to stick to delivering
some teaching and lectures online rather
than in person and what i love
is that i think i think it's oxford
correctly if i'm wrong i think it's
oxford
described that describe the use of
online learning as enhancing
uh the learning experience and another
college talks about a blend
of online and face-to-face teaching this
is simply not good enough and the reason
why it's not good enough
is because people now pay for their
tuition
and they pay an awful lot and for that
they have every right to expect to be
taught
face to face otherwise what is the point
of paying that amount of money
if you're relying upon lectures or
tuitions which are done by someone far
away
and pre-recorded given to lots of other
people etc etc
in the long run i i wonder if there's a
case for a radical rethink of the way if
we deliver higher education in this
country
if perhaps we should move more towards
online but the consequence of that
should be
that people don't pay as much for it
there's nothing wrong with a kind of
lifelong learning
a system where people can dip in and out
and study at different points in their
life and
online would seem to lend itself to that
much better but right now
expecting half of all kids to go to
university pay vast sums of money
in order to have a lecture on the
computer when
regular kids are back in school in the
classroom for free
that's frankly outrageous it's
interesting isn't it that
um there are we are now a situation
where some uni students have
only ever had an online uni experience
um let's start with the mail christina
this
this has been going on for four years
hasn't it tell us about this
alpaca called geronimo
well yes poor geronimo has um
in the age when we're all tested all the
time geronimo has had
two uh positive tb tests and
they are apparently extremely reliable
the margin for error
is almost non-existent um
his owner helen mcdonald claims that
the tests are wrong and that joanimo
doesn't have tv
and understandably she is desperate
she's very fond of him and he's
desperate to keep him alive
the government says he does have tv and
he's a threat
uh because bovine tv can spread
obviously to other animals and speaking
of someone whose
neighbor in northamptonshire has had to
see during the uh foot and mouth crisis
had to burn
huge piles of beloved animals i have to
say that
i think in these situations you do have
to follow where the sign
what the science says and if the science
says that an animal
is at serious risk of spreading
harm and disease then i'm afraid
tragically for helen mcdonald and
tragedy for
frantically for geronimo um he probably
does have to be put down but obviously
terrible for her and terrible for him
it is it really pulls at the heart
string or the heart strings doesn't it
tim because if it
if it was a cow he would have been put
down straight away but she
she her argument is that it's the tests
are not for alpacas
i don't know much about the science of
the test but i will say geronimo is a
very handsome
alpaca
very he's very good looking i didn't see
why i didn't see why he can't be moved
to some
some little island or something where
there's no risk of him yeah i think he's
got his own little island on the farm
he's he's in trouble no i'm sorry i feel
very differently
uh if i if jerome were mine i'd go on
the run with him
i would i would don't go on the run with
him because then if he has got tb
he'll be spreading it around the country
right i know but i can entirely
understand why she doesn't want
geronimo to be put down i i there must
be there must be another way
can we not have a special place for
animals like that where they've all got
it and they just
cough over each other i don't really
understand it but i don't want i don't
want this poor creature to die
yeah and i'm very sad to poor jerome
yeah i think she i've seen in another
paper that she said she's going to film
what she calls his
execution
yes i think it is quite dreadful indeed
but also tb i think hides very well in
the human body and then reap
in the body of any animal and then
reappears so
um let's leave it there on that sad news
about geronimo
um and hope he can find a a reprieve